Breaking fourth walls for aliens, forgoing
science for love, and reality versus illusion!
These bargain-basement endings left many
audiences feeling short-changed. But hey,
at least we got to see Batman fake
his own death - so there's that!
Directors have imagined the end of the world a
thousand times over, but audiences keep coming
back for more apocalyptic thrillers. A
doomsday film done right is always both
thrilling and thought-provoking, encouraging
viewers to wonder what these visions of the
future reveal about the state of humanity today.
Of course, an apocalyptic movie that ends on a
sour note just feels like a shoddy attempt at
indulging in spectacle without offering anything
of substance. That's exactly where director
Alex Proyas' 2009 film "Knowing" falls flat.
A young boy named Caleb discovers a page full
of mysterious numbers during a school event.
His astrophysicist father, John, discovers that
they represent the dates of big disasters — and
that the biggest disaster of all, a massive
solar flare, will happen in mere days. Just
before life on our planet is decimated, a
mysterious spaceship descends from the heavens,
with alien strangers beckoning Caleb and his new
friend, Abby, to come with them. The children are
whisked away to an Earth-like planet without
their parents, and the film ends abruptly.
As you'll see again later on this list, "it
was aliens" doesn't make for a particularly
compelling twist ending. There's more
questions raised than answers given — but
it doesn't seem like anyone is clamoring
for answers after that disappointing finale.
"What do you believe?"
"I think… s--- just happens."
The 1978 big-screen adaptation of "Superman"
starring Christopher Reeve is, without a shadow
of a doubt, a stone cold classic and a major
landmark in the history of superhero media.
The Richard Donner-directed film was one of the
first to approach its source material with both
ambition and seriousness, resulting in a sincere
and reverent adaptation that opened the door for
other filmmakers to do the same. Working
together, Donner and Reeve infused the Man
of Steel with humor and humanity, telling
the type of story that Superman fans had
waited decades for. For all the many assets
and accolades held by "Superman," however,
it also comes with one massive liability to many
fans: its infamously cheap time-reversing ending.
Like some of the other endings on this
list, "Superman" features an otherwise
complete finale to the film's events that's
quickly rewound and replaced with something
less satisfying. Rather than see Superman deal
with the emotional turmoil of losing Lois Lane,
theatrical audiences were treated to the hero
literally altering the rotation of the Earth
to do things over again. People could believe
a man could fly faster than a speeding bullet
and punch more powerfully than a locomotive, but
reversing time was just a bridge too far for some.
Despite an ending that feels disjointed
and incomplete, "10 Cloverfield Lane"
is worth a watch for sure. The pacing in Dan
Trachtenberg's intense thriller never lets up
and maintains an unrelenting, uncomfortably
tense atmosphere all the way through.
After Michelle is knocked out in a car accident,
she wakes up in a strange bunker with two men
she's never met. Howard, the owner of the bunker,
tells her that an event has occurred on the
surface that makes it uninhabitable, and that
she's only safe underground. As time goes on,
Michelle realizes that Howard is dangerous
— and if she wants a chance at surviving,
she'll have to take her chances topside.
She manages to barely escape Howard… but
when she makes her escape and
finally emerges from the bunker,
it turns out that the doomsday prepper
may not have been so crazy after all.
"'Crazy' is building your ark
after the flood has already come!"
That's right — it's aliens. After
barely avoiding a UFO's attacks,
Michelle makes her way to Houston to aid the
survivors of the invasion, and credits roll.
Audiences may not have been terribly
surprised by the sci-fi twist,
especially since the original "Cloverfield"
leaned into it hard. Still, a number of
viewers held out hope for something
a bit more subversive and grounded.
Steven Spielberg's 2005 film adaptation of "War
of the Worlds" follows Tom Cruise as Ray Ferrier,
a dockworker in New York who is estranged from
his daughter and son. He watches them while his
ex-wife goes out of town to visit her parents
in Boston — and while she's gone, things go
horribly wrong. After a series of lightning
strikes disrupt the power grid, some sort
of war machine rises from the ground and begins
vaporizing people, causing mass destruction. An
alien species is behind the attack, and Ray is on
a mission to protect his children and reunite them
with their mother. In the end, the entire family
miraculously survives and finds each other in
Boston, while the aliens are suddenly killed off
by the microbes that cover every surface on Earth.
As it turns out, even Spielberg agrees with
fans who think the movie wraps up a bit too
easily. The director is quoted in the book "James
Cameron's Story of Science Fiction" as saying —
"That film doesn't have a good ending. I never
could figure out how to end that darn thing."
Ever since "The Sixth Sense," it seems like most
of director M. Night Shyamalan's signature twist
endings have been misses rather than hits.
Although "Signs" is generally regarded as a
standout entry in his filmography, accepting
the ending requires some serious suspension
of disbelief. To be fair, it's a film about an
alien invasion, so it's not like every plot point
could be 100% plausible — but there's a glaring
hole in the reason behind the aliens' demise.
After extraterrestrials begin terrorizing
the planet and target his family,
former minister Graham Hess discovers that
simply splashing the aliens with water will
cause them to react as though they've been
burned, eventually killing them. The aliens
are now forced to quickly flee the planet
as they realize it's inhospitable for them.
"There's a monster outside my
room, can I have a glass of water?"
Here's the problem: the Earth is 70% water,
and usually there's plenty of moisture in the
air. The aliens would have been exposed
to water the moment they exited their
ships without suits. Does that make
"Signs" a bad movie? Not necessarily,
but its ending left a lot of people
feeling like the aliens: burned by H2O.
The ending of David Fincher's 1997 thriller
"The Game" is an odd case. Since its release,
fans and critics have voiced opposite opinions
about its effectiveness. One side considers it
unsatisfying and invalidating, while the other
side maintains that the invalidation is the
whole point. Whether or not the ending is just
the intended final turn of the titular game,
it's almost impossible to deny
that it feels pretty cheap.
The plot of "The Game" revolves around Michael
Douglas's character Nicholas becoming embroiled
in a series of increasingly bizarre and
existentially confusing circumstances. They
ultimately include Nicholas in a live burial and
a rooftop fratricide — so when it's revealed that
everything was staged, no one was actually hurt,
and nothing happened as Nicholas thought it did,
a lot of viewers have been left feeling cheated.
Even Nicholas' final prize — a shirt that says
"I was drugged and left for dead in Mexico
and all I got was this stupid T-shirt" — can
come across like a pointed jab at everyone
who had become invested in the narrative.
Some people adore the ending of "The
Game" for its boldness and absurdity,
but just as many were turned off by
its sudden and dramatic shift in tone.
The "Indiana Jones" franchise has captivated
audiences for decades. It began in 1981 with
"Raiders of the Lost Ark" and continued with
"Temple of Doom" and "Last Crusade" completing
before the decade was over. Nearly 20
years passed without another sequel,
until "Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull" premiered in 2008. An early scene
in which Indy survives an atomic explosion inside
a lead-lined fridge was the subject of hot debate,
but the ending was also so nonsensical that it
felt like a disservice to the entire franchise.
"What exactly am I being accused of
besides surviving a nuclear blast?"
"Kingdom of the Crystal Skull" wraps up by
waving away the entire plot with a simple,
yet overdone explanation: it was aliens. To top
it all off, after seeing a spaceship rise from
underneath an ancient city and watching some
of his colleagues get sucked into a vortex,
the final moments essentially just show
Indy returning to normal life. Indy has
witnessed some pretty wild supernatural
happenings in his first three adventures,
but somehow this sci-fi twist
feels like something else entirely.
The fan community's negative reaction to "Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull" is well documented at this
point. Whether it was the plot-armored
fridge or the extraterrestrial surprise,
it seemed like most people who saw the movie
when it came out had something to complain about.
Just like the 2011 film "Limitless,"
the plot of the science fiction movie
"Lucy" relies on the premise that human
beings only use 10% of our brains. This
often-repeated "fact" is nothing more
than a myth — but even if you accept it
as truth solely for the runtime of the film,
it still doesn't lead to a solid conclusion.
The titular protagonist Lucy is kidnapped by
drug mules, and ends up ingesting an illicit
substance that gives her the ability to use more
and more of her brain as time goes on. This gives
her superhuman powers, including telepathy,
telekinesis, and the inability to feel pain.
In the final moments of the film, Lucy finally
brings her cognitive power to full capacity,
and she journeys back in time through the
cosmos to the moment of the Big Bang. Her
physical body apparently becomes a flash
drive, yet she is able to send a text to a
police captain she had been working with
that simply states, "I am everywhere."
Talk about vague — it's unclear as
to why anyone thought that this film
would be best wrapped up with an ambiguous,
bite-sized nugget of philosophy from Lucy.
Have you ever seen a magician in action who was so
skilled at sleight of hand that for just a moment,
you were convinced that magic was real? That's
basically the idea behind "Now You See Me," but
kicked up more than a few notches. This infamous
film follows a group of four highly talented
illusionists called the Horsemen, who perform a
signature, mind-blowing trick: they extract money
from wealthy people's bank accounts and give it
to audience members. Naturally, the authorities
become suspicious of their activities,
and FBI agent Dylan Rhodes is on the case.
By the end of the film, however,
it's revealed that Rhodes himself
is actually an illusionist, too.
"Oh my God… I did not see that
coming. That's impossible!"
Rhodes had been working behind the scenes
as the fifth Horseman the whole time,
avenging his father's death by stealing from
the people responsible. The Horsemen are all
invited to join a secret society called the
Eye, and the film turns from a heist thriller
to something else entirely at the very last
second. With so little clarity over what's real
and what's merely an illusion, it's no wonder
that audiences left theaters feeling confused.
Based on the novel of the same name by Richard
Matheson, the post-apocalyptic film "I Am Legend"
follows U.S. Army virologist Robert Neville as
he struggles to survive each day in an eerily
empty New York City. The majority of those
who remain from a lethal viral outbreak have
mutated into zombie-like creatures known as the
Darkseekers. Neville spends the majority of his
time trying to find a cure for the virus,
eventually capturing a female Darkseeker to
experiment on. After three years with no one
but his German Shepherd to keep him company,
Neville finally meets two fellow survivors: a
woman named Anna and her son, Ethan. From there,
it's not long before the results
of his tests lead him to a cure.
When the Darkseekers come after Neville for
revenge, he's forced to sacrifice himself to
save Anna and Ethan, who protect the cure
and escape to a survivors' camp. However,
the ending of the director's cut follows
the theme of the novel more closely,
and completely flips the perspective of
the film in the process. In that version,
Neville interacts with the alpha male of the
Darkseekers, and returns without finding a
cure. He realizes that to the Darkseekers,
he has actually been the monster all along.
Though the theatrical cut is
not without its defenders,
the only opinion more popular than preferring the
director's cut is thinking that the ending
of Matheson's book wipes the floor with both.
The 2003 extreme French horror film "High Tension"
really seems like it was made twist-first,
with a story built around it to allow
the reveal to happen. As a result,
its ending has become one of the most commonly
cited in online discussions of bad endings,
even frequently proclaimed as one
of the worst twists of all time.
To make a long and excruciatingly bloody story
short, the dramatic twist at the end of "High
Tension" is that the film's slasher killer
was secretly one of the movie's two apparent
protagonists. That probably would've been
fine, if it didn't mean that the previous
events were physically impossible. Viewers are
expected to believe that a character is able
to be in two places at once — and that didn't
sit well with many, regardless of how good the
preceding hour might have been. Critic
Maitland McDonagh wrote for TV Guide —
"Unfortunately, they squander
their white-knuckle goodwill on
an 11th-hour about-face so preposterous it
undermines everything that preceded it."
Perhaps with some more clever writing,
"High Tension" could have stuck the
landing — but as it is, it's earned a pretty
understandable reputation as an illogical mess.
In all fairness to the cast
and crew of "Star Wars:
The Rise of Skywalker," there is no single
ending that could have pleased every single
one of the franchise's millions of fans.
Even with that in mind, however, it's hard
to call the ending the filmmakers ultimately
chose anything but cheap and unsatisfying.
"Somehow, Palpatine returned."
For a great many "Star Wars" enthusiasts,
the ending of "The Rise of Skywalker" was
the worst part of a trilogy that had already
featured several objectionable sequences. But
unlike the trilogy's other alleged faults, which
most often offended by ignoring characters and
canon from days of "Star Wars" past, the finale
committed an even worse, and even cheaper sin:
it blatantly erased the overarching story
of its own trilogy. Rey being the child of
"nobodies" showed that anyone can be a
Jedi, but "Episode IX" reversed that by
making her the granddaughter of one of
the franchise's most powerful bad guys.
There are too many offenses to list in "The
Rise of Skywalker," from the awkward kiss
to the fact that Palpatine is there at all —
but taken all together, it felt to many fans
that the ending was nothing more than a series
of rushed choices made to drum up nostalgia.
Alfred Hitchcock's "The Birds" — like the vast
majority of Hitchcock's films — is an excellent
piece of cinema with an enduring legacy and
pervasive influence. It introduced mainstream
audiences to an entirely new brand of horror,
one that generates effectiveness by remaining
vague throughout and never explaining itself.
A major component of that haunting ambiguity is
the film's ending, which consists of a mere fade
to black after the main characters drive away.
Though the birds have ceased their assault for
the moment, there is no answer as to whether or
not they'll begin again, only heightening the
terror. While the ending is an effective one,
it's also undoubtedly a cheap one — especially
given the fact that the original script included
an answer and resolution involving a
car chase, which Hitchcock simply cut.
Film scholars and enthusiasts are
of two minds about the ending of
"The Birds:" either its uncertainty
makes it thoughtful and effective,
or it finishes on an unsatisfactory note. No
one could ever dispute that it's a memorable
and influential horror classic, but the quality
of its ending is certainly up for debate.
Based on Don Winslow's novel of the same name,
Oliver Stone's 2012 thriller "Savages" essentially
devolves into little more than worn-out tropes
in the final scenes. Wealthy marijuana growers
Chon and Ben, who are in a polyamorous
relationship with their girlfriend Ophelia,
get caught up with a violent Mexican drug cartel.
Ophelia is kidnapped and held against her will to
prevent Chon and Ben from backing out of
the partnership and leaving the world of
crime. As the conflicts escalate, all of the
high-stakes drama culminates in a gunfight,
which naturally doesn't go as planned. Ben
is fatally wounded, and Chon administers
a lethal injection to Ben, Ophelia, and
himself so that they can all die together.
"That's the way I imagined it… but
the truth has a mind of its own."
Of course, the film ends up taking a different
turn. Ophelia wakes up very much alive,
revealing that the previous scene
was nothing but a nightmare as
DEA agents end up capturing some of the
high-ranking members of the cartel. The
three escape to an undisclosed tropical
island, where they live on the beach.
So it turns out that the stakes were pretty low
for the protagonists all along. It's no
wonder that "Savages" never received the
same acclaim as many of Oliver Stone's
other movies, like "Platoon" and "JFK."
It's no secret that the ending to James Cameron's
1997 historical epic "Titanic" has been met with
an ocean of deep, dark, frigid criticism since
its release. What may surprise you, however,
is that two entirely separate sequences in the
finale have generated mass derision, and both
for their own unique approaches of cheapness. Of
course, the infamous door scene leading to the
death of Jack has inspired an endless amount
of scrutiny, but so has the emotional wrap-up
sequence in the modern day, which ends with Rose
dying and meeting Jack in Heaven. That final
moment would be incredibly sweet if she didn't
also have a husband up there waiting for her too.
As anyone who's participated in discussions
about "Titanic" knows, though, it's the door
scene that has truly captured people's
attention. The question of whether or not
both lovebirds could have fit on the floating
door together has been raised for decades,
even prompting the Mythbusters to test it out
for themselves. In 2022, though, Cameron himself
revealed that he had funded a scientific study
with a hypothermia expert. He told Variety —
"We have done a scientific study
to put this whole thing to rest and
drive a stake through its heart once and for all."
During his arduous preparations for
"Interstellar," Christopher Nolan
went to great lengths to ensure the movie's
scientific accuracy. The director worked with
Nobel laureate in Physics Kip Thorne, whose
influence on the project extended from its
initial conception all the way through writing
and digital effects. The end result is a film
deeply rooted in the known behaviors of stars,
gravity, black holes, and relativity — until its
surreal ending, a sequence that many
fans consider frustrating and cheap.
After sacrificing himself by falling into a black
hole, astronaut Joseph Cooper finds himself in a
five-dimensional tesseract made by time-traveling
humans from the future. By communicating with his
daughter in the past, Cooper is able
to save humanity — and in the process,
he learns that the most powerful force in the
universe is not gravity or entropy, but love.
"Love is the one thing we're capable of perceiving
that transcends dimensions of time and space."
The heartstring tugging ending of "Interstellar"
certainly has its defenders, but many viewers
felt annoyed that the sci-fi epic didn't
stay rooted in scientific accuracy. Is it
a beautiful moment, or a disappointing
cop-out? That's up to you to decide.
Guillermo del Toro's 2017 fantasy romance
"The Shape of Water" is an excellent movie,
with a solid amount of awards and
critical ratings that speak for
themselves. There is simply no
deriding the Best Picture winner
as a whole — but that doesn't mean that
every one of its parts is untouchable.
Throughout the film, protagonist Elisa and her
amphibious lover are pursued by the evil Colonel
Strickland, who intends to dissect the creature
in the name of scientific progress. However,
after Elisa is tragically shot, it's the Amphibian
Man who slices Strickland's neck instead,
killing him in a twist of karmic justice.
Many viewers expected to see Elisa die in
her lover's arms — but the actual ending
ended up being a bit more controversial.
Elisa seemingly dies in the water,
only to be magically resurrected
and granted gills by the Amphibian Man. For many,
the sudden and unprecedented use of
a drama-neutralizing superpower to
undo previous story beats felt like a cop-out
along the lines of Superman's time reversal.
So what would have been a better
finale? In her essay for High on
Films, writer Pallavi Dandamudi wrote —
"Instead of the appearance of Eliza’s
gills, the movie could just have ended
with both of them in the water, holding on
to each other. It would still be ambiguous,
but the implications of that ending would
be different and far more powerful."
One of the most disappointing, frustrating types
of cheap movie endings is when a film decides to
end without addressing a main theme that it's
spent ample time setting up. It's worse when
that theme was built up over multiple films
— a trilogy, for instance. And of course,
it's even worse than that when the ending
directly contradicts the main theme instead of
simply ignoring it. Unfortunately for many fans
of Christopher Nolan's "Dark Knight" trilogy,
in their eyes, that worst-case scenario is exactly
what they got with "The Dark Knight Rises."
In order to prevent Bane's neutron bomb from
destroying Gotham, Bruce Wayne hooks it to
his airship and flies it over the bay. In his
final act as Batman, he sacrifices his life to
save the people of his city. At least, that's
what the movie wants you to think at first.
During the final scene in Florence, Italy,
Alfred sees Wayne alive and well. It turns
out that the hero actually faked his own
death, having fixed the autopilot function
in his flying machine. Wayne's survival,
along with the tacked-on reveal that police
officer John Blake's legal first name is
Robin, felt needless and pandering to many.
Jim Jarmusch is known for his thoughtful films
with independent sensibilities. His takes on
genre fare, from the martial arts mob flick
"Ghost Dog: The Way of the Samurai" to the
vampire romance "Only Lovers Left Alive," have
been met with critical acclaim. That's why,
when it was announced that Jarmusch's next
project would be a zombie comedy with what was
called "the biggest cast ever disassembled,"
fans of the filmmaker were pretty hyped.
Starring everyone from Bill Murray and Adam Driver
to Danny Glover and Tilda Swinton, "The Dead Don't
Die" ended up being an entertaining, albeit slow
meta-comedy in which a shift in the Earth's axis
has caused the deceased to start rising out
of their graves. So how did this rollicking
undead romp turn so many people against it by
the end? No, it couldn't be. There's no way…
Well, if you can believe it, it's aliens
once again. If you're surprised to see a
UFO make an appearance in this zombie flick,
you're not alone — so are the main characters,
who fully annihilate the fourth wall as
they remark on the bizarre plot development.
"Was that in the script?"
"No… not the one I read."
Jarmusch was almost certainly satirizing the trend
of twist ending aliens with his film's finale, but
many audience members who weren't in on the joke
left the theater with a bad taste in their mouth.